hello hello this is not a normal pot
cast we are not gonna be doing some fun
stuff there's gonna be no music sponsors
anything like that we just wanted to get
on here and talk to you guys for a
second about the last week and what has
gone on whether or not you've been aware
of it with the podcast so so yeah that's
what we're doing today do you want me to
whatever you want
basically we [ __ ] up so bad we [ __ ]
up really really bad as you guys know
the last couple podcasts we were digging
deeper into our no-sleep and we have in
the past done other podcasts from our
no-sleep and which if you're unfamiliar
with that means we've been going on to
reddit going on to certain subreddits
mainly one called no sleep and we've
been looking up stories that we thought
would be fun to read for the podcast and
we're fun to read for the podcast and we
did multiple episodes reading those
stories and reacting and we were sort of
treating them as part of Reddit and
they're not these are people's pieces of
intellectual creative property which we
infringe upon by reading them and
permission without permission beforehand
which we should have done and it says
clearly on the website that these
stories are protected and if you do not
have permission from the author
beforehand you will be DMCA struck down
by the hand of God which we fairly did
our podcasts containing these stories
were taken down because those are the
author's rights and I'm sorry we did
tweet this out and I saw a lot of
reactions from people being like right
it's a public forum and you know I don't
understand why and you know I don't
understand this because you really
enjoyed them obviously they're wonderful
stories it's not a conversation and it's
not open to interpretation it is it's
very black and white it's very black and
white and it is completely 100% our
fault for
reading stories on the podcasts that are
not ours and I'm sure a lot of those
authors would have been happy to give us
permission you know if they were
compensated or asked beforehand
depending you know whatever they wanted
that's a thing that those authors do and
we just are honestly stupid idiots and
didn't read that and didn't do that and
it was never ever ever sorry like it was
never our intention ever to undermine
that or to cause any of these people
stress or harm like I cannot emphasize
that enough that we did not do this with
any type of mal-intent
we're stupid idiots and I'm really so
sorry and the thing that I am most sorry
about is that these people are small
independent creators they're writers and
pirating work is a real fear and a real
issue and I know what it feels like to
wake up and be like hey that person's
using my thing and what do I do and what
are my rights in this situation and I
feel so terrible and genuinely sorry
that I ever made someone feel like that
or that they were in that position and
it's just it's not something I would
ever want to make someone feel and I'm
really apologetic for that and I I feel
like we were coming at this from oh
we're gonna read stories on reddit and
it was just a complete oversight on our
part and I just could not apologize
enough so we took those podcasts down
and worked well a couple of them were
taken down and good for y'all but I'm
I'm just so sorry and it's not gonna
happen again I promise you we we we were
made aware of the situation after we had
posted the podcast I actually we had
received emails from to our gentleman
podcast email
which I didn't see because I don't
regularly check that email we have a
team that helps us well my mom yeah your
mom in Rome but uh but yeah just to give
you guys an idea of what our team is
it's me and Julian do the podcast my mom
helps with the sponsors no your mom your
mom is the podcast she organizes all the
sponsors and coordinates everything and
then Rome it's like overseeing literally
everything else that we do online yeah
so it's a small team but but there's you
know we're just trying to kind of
explain how it happened and what it was
like for us so we got an email from
Sarah who wrote sisters of house Omega
the incredible story that we read and we
tagged her on our Twitter account we can
link her actual will link her website
below we got an email from her saying it
was very it was hard to read honestly
because she was coming at it from such
an professional and a nice humane way
saying like listen I'm a big fan of you
guys and honestly it's like an honor to
have you guys read any of my work but
it's kind of put me in a tough position
because I'm currently shopping this
story around to sell it to a different
podcast to this and that and you guys
have kind of heard yeah and it you know
that was the first communication we had
with one of the authors so we as soon as
this kind of all became aware you know
made aware to us we we dealt with them
privately we emailed them back we're
like hey listen we were so sorry
the podcast is down it was actually
taken down by DMCA from the other author
who wrote the awesome story of the sugar
the sugar daddy one her name's Gabby
she's a ready user and writes stories
and so that was taken down and then we
initiated direct communication with them
and we're doing everything we can to
make everyone feel like we've made it
right behind the scenes those podcasts
have been taken down I also want to echo
Jenna and say that I'm sorry between
reading stories playing games having
conversations this podcast is run pretty
much entirely fueled by the ideas that
come in on me and Jenna's brain on a
weekly basis and your suggestions and
your suggestions but you know this train
is
it's a very small train and sometimes we
have to really you know rely on each
other like Jenna would be like what do
you want to do this week and I'll have
to come up with something and I'll do
something and then I'll do that to her
one week and she'll be like we'll do
this and I want to take responsibility
because I logged on to read it I didn't
read the sidebar and I freely reproduced
content that wasn't mine and so I - I'm
really sorry I'm started the authors I'm
sorry to anyone who watched that or is
watching the situation and maybe feels
like we said a bad example because we
did and so this is this is us trying to
let you guys know that you're right we
[ __ ] up and we are sorry in addition
to that I'm incredibly grateful I'm
eternally grateful to have you your
support personally on all of our
projects that we do when you guys back
us up and gas us up and everything that
you you just have our backs I'm so
grateful for that but I will say that
when you come to the defense of creators
that you follow or are fans of with good
intentions sometimes that can be adding
fuel to the fire in ways that you may
not have intended to so in in defending
us in any sort of situation because you
want to have our back Wow it comes from
a good place
it can aggravate the situation and maybe
make some people ie in this situation
the author's feel like maybe they're
being harassed or maybe they're being
ganged up on and what did I do wrong
like all these people are mad at me and
so I just want you guys to remember that
that's a dynamic that exists and it's a
dangerous one on the Internet
when when fan bases and communities get
up in arms and they go after people or
they're defending very valiantly people
they follow and so we appreciate you
guys we do we it's her only grateful for
you supporting and backing us up I just
need all of you to really remember and
try to have a moment to think in
situations like this that yes I want to
back them up yes I love them and
whatever but will this have any
ramifications on other people that may
not deserve it
and in this situation I don't think it
got too bad because I think we kind of
got to it pretty quickly online and we
were
okay don't defend us like this is what
happened but I just wanted you to kind
of hear it out of my mouth and not in a
tweet that it you know being on the
other end of something like that is not
fun and they didn't ask for it they
didn't ask for a they deserve well they
did nothing wrong they wrote a story and
posted it online within their rights and
abilities to own all of the ownership of
that and we violated that we violate
that if you have any negativity please
direct it towards us and not those awful
yes and also with all of the negative
connotations that come with a DMCA
strike right and getting a video taken
off of someone's channel there are a lot
of negative connotations that come with
that based on like the last however many
years on the internet and all the events
and news stories that have happened I
get it but they did what was legally
within their ability to do and their
rights to do to protect what was there
and they did the right thing the podcast
was taken down and we have since private
and other podcasts that we're infringing
in a similar way to avoid situations
like this and we're looking into every
single way that we can reach out to
authors that we have used work of I know
this is all really long-winded and we
want well you know everything's okay
right everything's good this is a this
is a learning situation this is an
opportunity for us to learn from our
mistakes and to be better for the
experience moving forward not making the
same mistakes and respecting other
people's works and you know other people
as creators in general and not
forgetting the fact that you know every
little place on the internet has rules
and there's an overarching code that you
need to abide by and remember even if
you think it's something small or a
little story or a post or whatever so we
you know we've definitely had an intense
week but we've learned a lot from it and
we just wanted to let you guys know the
situation if you were completely under
Iraq this is what has happened if you
have watched and you wanted to hear from
us this is this is our this is our
response so to speak but moving forward
we're just you know we're not going to
make the same mistake like Jenna said
we're gonna do our best to
with our small but valiant team we're
gonna do our research and make sure our
content is good to go and and that the
heart of this really genuinely was a
mistake like this was not something that
we ever wanted to do on purpose or ever
put someone in this position and I think
when you talk about people that are
coming to our defense I think some
people are getting confused with the
fact that a lot of times we deal with
fair use content and you know well what
is that why can you use a vine or we you
know we've done whole podcasts with
movie music or actual music yeah and
this is a very different issue than fair
use these are two separate things and I
was not aware and that this was a
mistake on our part and I'm genuinely
sorry but these are protected pieces of
work that the author's own all rights to
and they have every ability and every
right to say you can't read that on your
podcast and I it's it's not a topic that
we can discuss it's it's not a diss very
it's like we said it's very black and
white there are rules and we broke them
and we're you know we paid the
consequences for the rules honestly I
kind of consider ourselves lucky because
I feel like in a situation where you're
infringing on the copyright if some
other person or people's work it can get
really messy really fast
and it can kind of blow up and I'm
feeling very fortunate that in this
situation it didn't and we had Gabby and
Sarah who reached out and they did what
was within their legal rights and we're
making it right with them and everyone's
cooperating everyone's happy you know
what I mean it's it could be a really
really much less pleasant situation and
so we're fortunate for that and we'll
take that as like wow we're lucky that
this is you know our learning experience
and we didn't have a whole I don't know
a whole maybe even like legal situation
happen because of something like this
and just in the future I hope there's
other people out there that can learn
from this mistake so that you don't make
the same mistake because like I said it
genuinely was a mistake we did not mean
to ever do this on purpose and the last
thing that I would ever want to make
anyone feel a smaller crater an
independent writer feel is that we
took advantage of their work or we did
something on purpose to maliciously hurt
them and I also another thing that I saw
I saw a lot was you know well it it gave
them exposure I just want to remind you
that that is not currency and we don't
live in a world where we play by Jake
Paul rules like that is not okay and
what we did was not right and that is
the heart of the issue right there and
it doesn't matter nothing matters the
podcasts are down we are not making any
money off of their stories and we will
not in the future and we are trying our
best to make right on what happened in
the past and that I'm I just would never
want to make someone feel the way that
we definitely probably made those people
feel and I'm genuinely sorry for that so
we'll live and we'll learn and we're
moving forward and we appreciate like we
said you guys supporting and
understanding what's going on it was
kind of a crazy week because the podcast
actually disappeared off Spotify and now
it's back and then the episodes were
disappearing and everyone was like what
the [ __ ] is going on and we were like
what the [ __ ] is going on so it's been
it's been a week but more importantly
it's been an opportunity to learn so
we're gonna take that with us and be
better moving forward and thank you for
listening and for caring and for
understanding the situation and thanks
again to Gaby and Sarah and potentially
the other artists that we will be
communicating with in the near future
about our mistake and making it right
and moving forward and just being better
all right and for the record you are
allowed to read no sleep so in the
future maybe in the actual subreddit we
ever won a like fully full circle make
this right what we can do in the future
is reach out to an author of a story
asked for permission beforehand and you
know if that person wants compensation
if that person just wants us to read it
whatever it's up to that person that is
the author we are allowed to do that in
the future and I think maybe someday it
might be nice for us to actually do that
the right
way I agree because I know that you guys
enjoy the stories that we all do and
that it doesn't mean that we can never
do it we just did it the wrong way
and there is a right way to do it and
plenty of people do and those authors
are very happy to have their short
stories read and shared and you know
their credit and their name is there and
everything is the right way
we just we did it the wrong way and it
was never on purpose and we didn't mean
to do it and we're trying our best to
make it right and to apologize and to
make sure that it never happens again
so yeah it's not that it will never
happen or it can never happen we just
need to make sure that we do it the
right way so that these people are
protected and their consent is given for
their work to be read and we respect all
y'all writers and independent creators
and I would never ever ever ever ever
want to make someone feel taken
advantage of yep
that's it I mean that's that's why we're
here today so thank you guys for
listening and staying staying tuned in
we'll be back with a regular podcast on
Monday and moving forward just regular
schedule but we wanted to just get on
here and voice our actual voices instead
of a tweet because sometimes it can be
hard to understand what's going on or
tone gets lost or whatever so thank you
and yeah that's it for us we're very
sorry and we'll see you guys soon bye
bye